Gladbach die deutsche
tischtennis-nationalmannschaft der
Männer hat das WM-Finale gegen Gastgeber
China mit 0:3 verloren damit hat sich
das chinesische Team zum zehnten Mal in
Folge den WM-Titel geholt die deutsche
Mannschaft wertete ihren zweiten Platz
als großen Erfolg denn sie waren nur mit
der Zweitbesetzung angetreten
und nun die wettervorhersage für morgen
Montag den 10 Oktober
inne nach dem Süden und dann im Osten
Wolken später bildet sich hier unter
Nebel am Vormittag lösen sich die
Nebelfelder auf in der Südosthälfte mehr
Sonne als Wolken sonst werden die Wolken
dichter Richtung nordwestenfeld Regen
Richtung Südwesten und an den Alpen
einzelne Schauer oder Gewitter
in der Nacht 10 Grad auf Sylt ein Grad
in den Mittelgebirgen am Tag 15 Grad in
Nordfriesland 24 Grad am Kaiserstuhl
[Musik]
die phönix-wahlrunde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ein Vertrauensbeweis in einer
sehr schweren Zeit so nennt Stefan weil
SPD sein Ergebnis er ist Wahlsieger er
kann Ministerpräsident in Niedersachsen
bleiben und sein Wunsch Bündnis mit den
Grünen kann die große Koalition dort
ablösen die CDU hat stark verloren die
FDP muss zittern ob sie den Einzug in
den Landtag schafft was heißt das für
die Ampelkoalition in Berlin und welche
Schlüsse muss auch die Opposition aus
diesem Wahlergebnis ziehen unsere
Analyse zu den bundespolitischen
Auswirkungen der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen jetzt hier mit diesen
Gästen die alle seit vielen Jahren die
Bundespolitik beobachten herzlich
willkommen Christina Dunz vom
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschlands die
stellvertretende Leiterin des
parlamentsbüros und war zuvor bei der
Rheinischen Post genannt ich begrüße
Sabine rennefan sie ist Kolumnistin beim
Tagesspiegel und war zuvor politische
Redakteuren bei der Berliner Zeitung
schönen guten Abend Christoph
Schwennicke ist bei uns Publizist
Kolumnist bei T-Online und früher
Spiegel Süddeutsche und Cicero also eine
geballte Ladung Bunde logischer
Expertise hier und bevor wir hier
diskutieren aber noch einmal einen Blick
auf die letzten Zahlen schauen wir auf
die letzte Hochrechnung für die
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen danach
kommt die SPD auf
33,2 Prozent die CDU auf 28,1 grüne 14,5
FDP wie gesagt muss zittern 4,9 im
Moment
11,2 die AFD und die sonstigen auf 8,1
Prozent in Gewinnen und Verlusten heißt
das die SPD hat 3,7% verloren die CDU
starke Verluste mit 5,5 Prozent die
Grünen haben zugelegt 5,8 Prozent die
FDP auch verloren -2,6 die AFD hat stark
zugelegt 5,0 und sonstige 1,0 für die
sind Sitzverteilung im niedersächsischen
Landtags so aus 135 Sitze gibt es zu
verteilen 52 gehörten dann der SPD der
CDU 44 grün 22 und 17 für die AFD das
würde für die Koalitionsmöglichkeiten
Folgen des bedeuten rot-schwarz das ist
ja das Bündnis was jetzt regiert hätte
in diesen in diesem neuen Landtag 96
Prozent 96 sitze und Rot-Grün 74 sitze
also damit wäre die Mehrheit von 68
sitzen gesichert das war eine Wahl in
Niedersachsen Herr Schwennicke aber war
das auch eine Abstimmung über die
Ampelkoalition in Berlin
tun immer nicht gut daran so zu tun als
würde in jedem Bundesland eine kleine
Bundestagswahl stattfinden aber trotzdem
stimmt eines umgekehrt die Auswirkungen
einer Landtagswahl die kannst du dann
schon im Bund wieder ablesen und die
massivste Auswirkungen wird das
Abschneiden der FDP haben die jetzt
wahrscheinlich doch fix und final
draußen ist das hat man finde ich auch
in den ersten Äußerungen der diversen
runden die jetzt schon stattgefunden
haben festgestellt die FDP lohnt sich
erkennbar am schwersten in dieser
Ampelkoalition hier in Berlin und lässt
es sich nach meinen Dafürhalten um
dreien leider auch noch anmerken also
ist immer in so einer etwas innere
Oppositionellen Haltung
Grüne und FDP sind wie Hund und Katze
und das hätte ich übrigens so nicht
erwartet ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
die ideologischen Gräben immer noch so
tief sind sind sie aber und um in diesem
Bild zu bleiben die FDP klefft da immer
sehr stark und das macht sie noch
schwächer als Ionen schon ist und das
ist auch ein Teil des der Erklärung für
dieses schwache Wahlergebnis in meinen
Augen das wird die Nervosität bei den
Liberalen größer werden lassen
wie sehen Sie es wie stark stand diese
Ampelkoalition dort auch zur Wahl also
ich glaube dass die stand gar nicht zur
Wahl also wenn wir uns mal angucken SPD
auf Bundesebene
Scholz heißt sehr lange sehr schlechte
Werte die SPD hatte glaube ich in den
Umfragen ob Bundesebene 18 Prozent oder
so während weil ja sehr viel populärer
da wirklich ein Amtsbonus hatte und die
SPD ja jetzt fast ja 15 Prozent mehr
auch in Niedersachsen eingefahren hat
also ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen
nach hinten losgegangen das hat ja die
CDU Niedersachsen versucht das so als
Wahl über die Ampel zu drehen aber das
hat letztlich nicht funktioniert also
wobei man natürlich doch auch sagen kann
was ich wirklich hoch spannend finde SPD
Niedersachsen das ist eigentlich der
Landesverband wo alle unsere Probleme
mit der Energie herkommen also Gerhard
Schröder ja und auch Steinmeier also
Nord Stream 2 und so weiter und da
spielte überhaupt keine Rolle im
Wahlkampf
aber Ursache und Wirkung und wie das die
walische SPD geschafft hat das so
rauszulassen das finde ich schon sehr
interessant also Frau Dr uns wie sehr
stark stand Olaf Scholz da auch mit der
bundesweit nicht so gute Umfragen hat
und die SPD oder war es ganz klar eine
Abstimmung über Herrn weil und eben
nicht über die Ampel ich glaube was den
ganzen Wahlkampf überlagert hat ist sehr
wohl die bundespolitische Situation die
Menschen haben von nichts mehr Angst im
Moment als vor steigenden Energiepreisen
und wie sie den Winter finanziell
überstehen oder ob sie frieren müssen
und das schwingt bei natürlich bei
Wählerinnen und Wählern in einem Bundes
in einem Bundesland auch mit und
insofern kann man zumindest sagen dass
Stefan weil nicht nicht unbedingt
Rückenwind von von der SPD und der Ampel
hat und ist trotzdem geschafft hat was
meiner Ansicht nach auch daran liegt
dass die SPD ja seit dem Bundestagswahl
etwas geschafft hat wozu sie jahrelang
nicht in der Lage war nämlich
zusammenzurücken und Stefan weil und
Olaf Scholz sind keine großen Freunde
und trotzdem haben sie eine Politik
gemeinsam gemacht sich in einer
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht
obwohl die dramatisch
Blut leer geblieben ist aber sie haben
sie sind nicht auseinandergefallen und
das davon hat die SPD profitiert wo von
jetzt herr Scholz zum Ende dieses Jahres
mit diesem Wahlsieg natürlich auch noch
mal gestärkt wird also damit kann Scholz
dann auch wieder profitieren zumindest
auch auf seine Fahnen schreiben selbst
wenn er sagt Stefan weil hat gewonnen
weil besser als Olaf Scholz
naja er hat schon zwei
Legislaturperioden regiert ich habe es
eingangs gesagt oder sagst jetzt ein
Ministerpräsident hat in den Bundesland
eine enorm starke Position und Rolle
dieser Bonus für ein Ministerpräsident
ist noch ungleich größer als für ein
Kanzler oder eine Kanzlerin dieser
Mensch reißt die ganze Zeit durchs Land
kennt alle per Handschlag du musst
andersrum gesagt schon sehr sehr viel
falsch machen um nicht aus dieser
Position der Stärke raus wiedergewälzt
werden und jedenfalls
Kurfürst ein Ministerpräsident und
jedenfalls aus der Mitteldistanz hier
aus Berlin hat Herr weil jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig viel falsch gemacht er ist
vielleicht kein großer Entertainer und
hat auch keinen großen Glamour aber die
Niedersachsen sind da vielleicht auch
eher sagen wir mal
genügsam was diese Eigenschaften anlangt
so ein Herz solide Politik gemacht
vielleicht spielt sogar eine Rolle dabei
er hat tatsächlich ein bisschen
Prozentpunkte verloren es liegt
sicherlich an den Ängsten der Leute das
Energie teurer wird aber vielleicht hat
er davon profitiert dass man sagt der
ist in der gleichen Partei wie der
Bundeskanzler für vielleicht schadet das
auch gar nicht dieser direkte Draht ich
sehen übrigens nicht so weit weg von
Olaf Scholz also die sehe ich beide so
in dieser pragmatischen Ecke der SPD ja
gut dass das kann ich gar nicht
beurteilen muss ich sagen aber sie sind
beide innerhalb der SPD da mal politisch
auf der auf dem gleichen pragmatischen
Kurs würde ich sagen und Herr Althusmann
du tust dich halt sehr sehr schwer
aus der großen Koalition heraus als der
kleinere Partner dann als Konkurrent
anzudrehen also du liegst mit dem
Doppelbett und sollst dann da
Ministerpräsident werden das ist sehr
sehr schwer er hat jetzt auch wenn ich
das vorhin aus dem Augenwinkel richtig
gesehen habe auch schon die Konsequenzen
gezogen und tritt nicht mehr anders
Landesvorsitzender genau dann noch dazu
genau ich wollte dazu noch gerade was
sagen wobei Herr weil schon auch eine
gewisse Distanz zu Scholz hat erkennen
lassen also so habe ich das zumindest
gesehen
einer der ersten der zum Lager
kritisiert hat also und es damit auch
offen nach außen getreten also relativ
früh als das noch
keiner sonst in der SPD auch gemacht hat
und es gab zwar gemeinsame Auftritte von
den beiden aber die waren eher auch
dosiert ja also das weiß nicht dieser
enge Schulterschluss von dem Kevin
Kühnert vorher hin zum Beispiel sprach
ne also sind es auch beides norddeutsche
und eher kühlere Temperamente natürlich
auch
dass das kommt noch das kommt noch hinzu
genau da ähneln sie sich ja okay dann
gucken wir auf die auf die CDU natürlich
also die CDU hat stark verloren Bernd
Althusmann hat eben die Konsequenzen
schon gezogen inwieweit war das ein
abstrafen von Friedrich Merz also fast
meiner Ansicht nach sicherlich eine
Rolle gespielt hat ist der Ausspruch von
Friedrich Merz vor vor kurzem dass er
geflüchtete Ukrainerin dass er diesen
Frauen sind ja überwiegend Frauen
sozialtourismus
geworfen hat in einer Situation wo ein
Land droht vernichtet zu werden wo
Frauen mit Kindern fliehen also man
magst man muss sich dieses Elend
wirklich im Detail vorstellen davon
sozialtourismus zu sprechen und ist
nicht genau zu erklären was er gemeint
hat er hatte das ja in einem anderen
Zusammenhang dann im Nachhinein
dargestellt das ist glaube ich eine
Sache wo
christdemokratische Wählerinnen und
Wähler zusammenzucken und sagen so
wollen wir das nicht und bei wem es
eingezahlt hat ist die AFD was ja aber
er hat sicher entschuldigt ja er hat
sich entschuldigt und er sagt dann immer
er bedauert das aus tiefstem Herzen ich
glaube dass viele ihm das so nicht
abnehmen und ich schätze es auch so ein
dass das nicht wirklich bedauert er
wollte diesen Punkt
ich nehme ihm ab dass er bedauert dass
er dadurch Kritik und Gegenwind bekommen
hat und nicht die Claqueure erreicht hat
die er wollte für seine Partei ich
glaube ihm nicht dass er das an sich
bedauert und das ist meiner Ansicht nach
auch ein bisschen das gespüren der CDU
dass sie eben nicht wollen
Hubertus Heil hat heute gesagt ich fand
das einen guten Ausdruck auf die
populistische Hupe zu drücken und das
hat März damit gemacht und damit ist ein
Teil der Partei nicht einverstanden und
insofern glaube ich dass das dem
Spitzenkandidaten in Niedersachsen Bernd
althus man auch geschadet hat okay
würden sie das auch so das ist nicht so
einschätzen weil noch mal wir neigen
immer sehr dazu eins zu eins dann
landtagswahlergebnisse auf die hiesigen
Protagonisten zu übertragen ich bin
völlig einer Meinung was diesen Vorgang
mit diesem Begriff anlangt ich weiß auch
nicht genau was kalkuliert so ein
bisschen in den Wahlkampf hinein oder
Basen ausrutsche oder was Vorsatz ich
weiß es nicht aber wenn wir uns jetzt
mal die letzten drei Landtagswahlen
zusammen anschauen dann haben wir
vielleicht sogar hier bei Ihnen Frau
blättner gesessen und gesagt auch guck
mal da hat jetzt der März eine
Landtagswahl gewonnen also in
Schleswig-Holstein und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und jetzt hat er
eine verloren er hat im Saarland hat die
SPD gewonnen aber natürlich auch kleiner
als noch immer so Saarland lassen wir
mal weg das ist eine Kommunalwahl ich
bitte alles
nachzusehen und so wie man auf der einen
Seite nicht sagen sollte nur weil
Hendrik wüst
wiedergewählt wurde gut er hat es ererbt
als Ministerpräsident aber trotzdem
wieder gewählt wurde und wie Daniel
Günther in Schleswig-Holstein wieder
gewährt und noch mal Ministerpräsident
Präsidenten Amtsbonus so würde ich jetzt
auch nicht über betonen das ist es so
dass
die Vize Vorsitzende CDU insofern kann
ich ja selbst in der Partei also in der
Spitze Stellvertreterin von Friedrich
Merz hat gesagt das habe sicherlich
nicht geholfen es ist ja nun wirklich
eine Formulierung was eigentlich rechts
links eine Ohrfeige ist und insofern das
ist die auch die Einschätzung der parte
in der Parteispitze selbst die würden
sie das Sehen diesen Ausdruck des
sozialtourismus das ist so eine ich
glaube das waren Fehler in taktischer
Fehler von von Friedrich Merz das hat
also ich glaube dass Bernd altusmann die
Wahl auch ohne das verloren hätte aber
das hat wirklich nicht geholfen und ich
glaube auch ich habe mich ein bisschen
gewundert ehrlich gesagt dass Friedrich
Merz das gemacht hat weil wir haben ja
den Vorläufer gesehen also Markus Söder
hat das ja auch mal versucht
asyltourismus vor einigen Jahren dass
mochten die Bayern die csu-wähler auch
überhaupt nicht das ist nach hinten
losgegangen und immer wieder diese
Versuche dass die CDU versucht so ein
bisschen am rechten Rand zu wildern zu
graben das funktioniert halt nicht das
wird halt nicht so gutiert wird wie von
uns auch das auch schon gerade sagte das
kommt nicht so gut an ich glaube aber
dass die CDU in Niedersachsen auch noch
sehr viele andere hausgemachte Probleme
hat aber wenn man jetzt sagt das kommt
nicht an oder auch vielleicht die
Diskussion weil Energie ein wichtiges
Thema war um die Atomkraft die
Verlängerung der Atomkraftwerke kam
vielleicht nicht so an ist das wenn man
das Ergebnis sieht sozusagen ein eine
starke Bestimmung zu Rot-Grün das ist ja
auch dann die wunschkoalition die jetzt
dann auch möglich ist in Niedersachsen
das finde ich noch ein bisschen
schwierig zu beurteilen
was die Atomkraft betrifft wenn man nah
an so einem Kernkraftwerk lebt ich bin
da aufgewachsen in der Nähe dann hat man
eine in so einem Bundesland eine andere
Beziehung dazu und ich würde sagen eine
doch ängstlichere und wenn man mal
überlegt was das bedeutet wenn man die
auch dieses Kernkraftwerk weiterlaufen
lassen würde dass die Brennstäbe müssten
erneuert werden wenn es jetzt wirklich
über 323 hinausgehen würde am Ende
kommen sie noch aus Russland und der
Sicherheitscheck ist zehn Jahre her das
heißt also eine wirklich hoch riskante
Technologie und da sind die
Niedersachsen oder ein Teil der
Niedersachsen sehr nah bei den Grünen
und auch dann an einer rot-grünen
Regierung aber ist davon mal ganz
abgesehen es würde ja noch locker für
die große schon reichen und aber bald
hat ja vorher immer klar gemacht
die dieser aufwuchs der Grünen in in
Niedersachsen ist schon eines der zwei
drei bemerkenswertesten einer der
bemerkenswertesten Aspekte dieses
Wahlausgangs denn also strukturell ist
Niedersachsen eher konservativ es ist
ein sehr agrarisch geprägtes
landwirtschaftlich geprägtes Land
vielleicht kann man da daraus auch
ablesen dass vielleicht auch die
Landwirtschaft auch in Niedersachsen
schon eine in Anführungszeichen grünere
geworden ist dass also auch Landwirte
sich eher vorstellen können mit dieser
Partei ihren politischen Frieden zu
machen als früher
diesen diesen zweiten Aspekt da damit
mit reingeben und es ist schon
interessant dass ich komme noch mal auf
diesen Punkt zurück das unter den beiden
Berliner Koalitionspartnern der SPD also
den kleineren koalitionspanodie ein so
stark zulegen und zum anderen so Federn
lassen müssen und da würde ich mir sie
haben gesagt in der CDU wird schon
diskutiert was Herr März falsch gemacht
hat da würde ich an an der Stelle der
Liberalen noch mal darüber nachdenken ob
es wirklich so gut ist sich so stark als
innerparteilich Opposition zu gebärden
oder eben diese etwas ich sage es mein
staatsmanager einzunehmen wie es wie es
die Grünen auf der bundespolitischen
Ebene getan haben und offensichtlich
damit mehr Erfolg haben als die
Liberalen ja die Liberalen das hat der
Generalsekretär immer der Berliner Runde
auch eben klar noch mal gesagt sehr
Reihe dass wir jetzt noch stärker unsere
Positionen durchsetzen müssen
in dem Moment weil das wieder in diese
Richtung geht die ich meine also da ist
keine Souveränität da ist erkennbar
Nervosität und das ist nicht attraktiv
für Wählerinnen und Wähler naja wenn das
jetzt wirklich in die Richtung geht dass
die sich dann noch mehr streiten und
noch mehr Zank ich glaube dass fällt
dann nicht auf Olaf Scholz zurück oder
auf die Grünen sondern dass wir das also
damit würden sich die würden sich die
Liberalen eigentlich noch stärker rein
reiten also ich wundere mich ein
bisschen ich würde eher sagen die müssen
doch eigentlich wirklich verstehen es
sollte war ja auch der Anspruch
ursprünglich dieser Koalition Loyalität
Zusammenarbeit Fortschritte Koalition es
funktioniert halt nicht wenn also wenn
dann gesagt wird ja wir werden dann
irgendwie gegen alles im Prinzip sein
also weil so ziemlich genau vor einem
Jahr als also nach der Bundestagswahl
war ja gerade auch dieses selfie mit
Grünen und FDP wo man das Gefühl hatte
da geht es was ganz Neues und das ist
aber jetzt nicht mehr aber zur Wahrheit
gehört natürlich auch das Lindner
Christian Lindner vor der Wahl noch
gesagt hat ihm viele für eine
Ampelkoalition Zitat die Fantasie dann
hat er die Fantasie plötzlich doch
aufgebracht aber vielleicht
ist da doch mehr Wahrheit drin als man
gedacht hat ich räume ja auch ein ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass das Gelb und
Grün noch so sehr aufeinander allergisch
reagieren wie wir es in dieser Koalition
erleben und auch die beiden also ich
meine Lindner und habe schienen noch
auch so fast so was wie eine
Männerfreundschaft irgendwie zu haben
also dass die so eine Art
es wirkt nichts also Lindner wollen mit
Scholz eine Männerfreundschaft aufzeigen
aber mit Harbeck also das war so eine
ganz kurze Zeit am Anfang
auch wenn habe ich sogar mit dem
FDP-Spitzenkandidat verschwägert ist
aber das hast du jetzt noch in
Niedersachsen
wie sehen sie es also ist das jetzt so
ein Punkt wo man sieht also eigentlich
kann das nicht funktionieren mit der
Ampel jetzt das ist so eine so eine
Stunde der Wahrheit wo man und wo sie
das jetzt auch noch mal wo ist der jetzt
sowieso schon knirscht wo es jetzt noch
mal härter Knirschen wird Herr Lindner
hat heute Abend als eine Reaktion gesagt
dass er selbstverständlich um die
Verantwortung der Partei für das Land
und die Menschen weiß und dass er ein
Amtseid geschworen hat damit hat er ganz
deutlich gemacht er wird diese Koalition
nicht krachen lassen hat auch gesagt
also das was er ja immer wieder betont
hatte dass das zwischen FDP und Grünen
nicht so gut funktioniert und dass er
quasi in so ein linkes Lager jetzt
gesteckt wird nur weil mit Rot-Grün
regiert und er hat gesagt man wird das
Ergebnis und die die Inhalte die dazu
geführt haben überdenken und das ist für
mich ein ganz ganz interessanter Punkt
weil Herr Lindner überdenken müsste was
ein Kurs in der Schuldenbremse ist also
er will die
Schuldenbremse wieder einsetzen es soll
dann wieder der Haushalt
zusammengehalten werden und das hat er
ja mit einem Mantra die ganze Zeit
erklärt dass auch in der Wirtschaft
Unternehmen Angst bekommen haben dass ob
die FDP das noch richtig einschätzt also
weil sie ja dann irgendwann auch Hilfen
brauchen und wenn man ein Finanzminister
hat der den Kurs aus dem Wahlkampf und
der Partei wirklich Eisen hat durchzieht
während andere in der Koalition ihre
ihre
Kernthemen aufkündigen wie die wie die
Grünen im bei der bei der Kohle sie
weiterlaufen zu lassen als ein Beispiel
das hat man innerhalb der FDP auch dem
Parteichef nicht also auch ein bisschen
negativ angekreidet und ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf ob er die Schuldenbremse
ob er das überdenkt oder ob er weiter
auf Konfrontation gehen würde ich würde
sagen das ist im Moment noch offen ist
Lindner dann der richtige Mann um diese
Ampelkoalition vorzusetzen oder ist das
sowieso die FDP hat gar keinen anderen
entsprechend gar keine Frage Antwort
gegeben ja und ich glaube ich glaube am
Ende auch wir dürfen nicht unterschätzen
dass macht ist schon ein sehr starker
Klebstoff und natürlich haben wir
Journalisten auch
unsere Freude ist jetzt vielleicht nicht
ganz das richtige Wort aber wir schauen
natürlich immer dahin wo es knirscht und
wo es wo es ein bisschen knarzt dafür
sind wir auch da aber
die die
Koalitionspartner wissen schon ganz
genau was sie aufs Spiel setzen wenn sie
jetzt dafür haftbar gemacht werden
politisch bei der Wahl die dann anstünde
dass sie diese Koalition am platzen
lassen das wird von Wählerinnen und
Wählern überhaupt nicht gutiert und
deswegen wird ich kannte diesen Spruch
aufgestanden heute den aktuellen von
Christian Lindner nicht aber der deutet
ja schon in die Richtung dass er alles
tun möchte um diesen Eindruck zu
vermeiden der kann es sich mein Ansicht
nach auch überhaupt nicht leisten weil
er ja die
jamaika-koalitionsverhand ist
sondierungsverhandlungen waren es 2017
hat platzen lassen und das haftet ihm
natürlich an und wenn er jedes Mal
abbiegt wenn es richtig schwierig wird
dann wäre er auch als parteiche
vermutlich schwer haltbar aber wenn wir
jetzt sagen Energie war so wichtig und
auch die die Sorgen der Menschen dass
ihre Energiepreise nicht zahlen können
welchen Schluss muss man denn dann
ziehen aus diesem Ergebnis
ich würde eigentlich ganz gerne noch wir
haben jetzt über die Grünen die
eingewinner geredet ich würde eigentlich
auch noch ganz gerne über die anderen
Gewinner reden und dann kommen wir auch
gleich auf die auf die auf die
Energiepreise das fand ich nämlich auch
ganz interessant einer der größten also
bei den wählerwanderungen einer der
größten Bewegung war von der FDP zu der
AFD ne ähm und das sagt ja auch schon
einiges ne also AFD auch genau genau von
der SPD zu den Nichtwählern und zu und
zu AFD das fand ich hoch interessant AFD
ist eigentlich in Niedersachsen fast gar
nicht existent also dieser Wahlerfolg
hat mit dem mit der Partei dort vor Ort
gar nichts zu tun das ist eine reine
viel Streit die waren ja total zerlegte
Haufen die Warnung wieder fraktionslos
sozusagen und haben trotzdem dieses
Ergebnis eingefahren also so eine reine
Protestwahl und glaube ich auch alle
Leute die jetzt
ja AKWs also die Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen wollen sie haben dann eher
die AFD gewählt weil die da sehr stark
fordert das stimmt aber man hat
natürlich diesen Protest und diesen
diesen Schock Effekt den hat man
natürlich viel stärker wenn man die wenn
man seinen Kreuz bei der bei der AFD
macht also das sagen würden Sie sagen
ist der Grund für den Zuwachs der AFD
absolut wie sehen sie ist einfach wieder
Wut Zeit ja und eine Partei die aus
schlechter Laune immer Kapital zu
schlagen versucht hat dann wieder fährt
dann wieder eine gute Ernte ein das ist
so
ich kann ja leider auch nichts dran
ändern dass
diese Leute die da auf ihn sind nicht
die Frage stellen was bieten ja ich
konkret und dann an ich finde da fehlt
ein bisschen also dagegen zu sein ist
alles in Ordnung ist auch das gute Recht
und man darf auch demonstrieren und
alles aber das in den letzten Jahren
konnte man immer gucken wenn Wut Zeit
ist aus welchem Anlass auch immer dann
ist Hochkonjunktur für die für die AFD
und das ist jetzt wieder der Fall den
letzten Landtagswahlen hat sie ja
jeweils verloren ja da war aber auch der
Corona das war genug Wohnzeit ja aber
die das kulminiert jetzt natürlich schon
stärker als vorher also
wir haben Corona immer noch und sagen
wir mal die
die corona-depression auch noch nicht
ganz abgestreift tragen ist immer noch
mit uns rum alle ja nicht nur
afd-wählerinnen und Wähler die
Kriegssituation ist da Inflation
Rezession und
energiepreisängste kommen dazu das ist
natürlich eine Platte für eine Partei
wie die AFD aber ist es so Frau sonst
würden sie auch sagen es ist reiner
Protest
es gibt einen Teil der Bevölkerung der
sich wirklich abgehängt fühlt also wenn
man das da muss man der Ampelkoalition
einfach Stückwerk vorhalten erstmal in
dem Entlastungspaket Rentner und
Studierende nicht bedacht jetzt bei
jetzt wird es ganz entscheidend darauf
ankommen wie der
gaspreisdeckel wie auch immer aussieht
es
also als ein Beispiel deswegen wäre
wahrscheinlich eine Einmalzahlung für
viele das was Sie sich am meisten
wünschen
viele Leute haben im letzten Jahr und in
den Jahren davor schon extrem gespart
auch an Strom und Gas
wenn man jetzt einen Deckel einführen
würde dann und das auf dem
Vorjahresniveau macht dann werden genau
diese Leute bestraft und das sind das
sind Menschen die sagen Rot-Grün
ruiniert mein Leben und wir können das
nicht bezahlen also gucken wir woanders
hin vielleicht auch als eine wenn sie
sagen rot-grünen erleben die ihre Stimme
nicht der CDU
ja das haben sie ja also es ist jetzt
also sie haben sechs Prozentpunkte
verloren die CDU das ist jetzt ist es
zwar das schlechteste
Ergebnis seit 1955 das ist schon wahr
aber sie sind ja jetzt auch nicht in den
Keller gerauscht und klar sie haben
das nicht also Bernd Althusmann hat das
nicht besetzen können selbst als als
Wirtschaftsminister nicht aber wenn man
sich die Gesamtlage im Land anguckt
dieser unglaubliche Druck auch die Angst
was aus dem Krieg dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine wird
dann haben natürlich Parteien wie die
AFD große Chancen das was Herr
schwennige gerade gesagt hat
Protestpotenzial aufzufangen und wenn
man sich überlegt was die erzählen also
nordsangst ist ja den als er die Russen
schädigt und den genau und die
Sanktionen also und da gibt es diese
verschiedenen also ich meine selbst da
Robert Habeck spricht von einem
energiekrieg ja also was und das ist so
also ich glaube da gab es einfach ganz
viele kommunikative Fehler die die Ampel
auch geleistet hat neben vielen anderen
handwerklichen Fehlern dass die Leute
oft nicht verstehen diese Sanktionen
warum machen wir die eigentlich und war
was haben wir davon warum ist das
wichtig dass wir das jetzt durchhalten
warum wie lange kann das also auch
erklären dass das jetzt vielleicht nur
ein vorübergehender Zustand ist ja also
der Scholz hat dann immer so diese
Ansätze ja wohl never you never walk
alone und ihr müsst euch unterhaken und
da kommt aber nichts das ist so ein
bisschen wie so diese
295 Milliarden Euro sollen auf dem Weg
gebracht werden insgesamt ja die sind
aber noch nicht verteilt die sind da
wissen wir noch nicht mal wer die
bezahlt also und in anderen Ländern gibt
es ja viel klarere schnellere Reaktionen
und da ist einfach sehr also sehr lange
ja gewartet und auch gezaudert worden so
er Schwenningen und es gibt viele Leute
die haben Angst ihre dass Ihre Rechnung
nicht bezahlen können die wirklich dann
ja Probleme haben die gehen aber nicht
zu den linken erklären Sie sich das die
Linken haben jetzt waren die haben 2,6
Prozent bekommen in Niedersachsen auch
im Bund sind die Werte ganz schlecht die
aber doch ganz klar auf die Fahnen
geschrieben hat wir sind da für die
sozialen
also fairerweise muss man sagen die die
Linke hatte jetzt in Niedersachsen noch
nie so wirklich goldenen Boden und unter
den Füßen aber sie haben ja gesagt im
Bund ist die Lage auch nicht auch nicht
viel besser die Linke hat sich ein Stück
weit selbst zerlegt im Moment oder ja
ist dabei es zu tun
da hat für meine Begriffe das Ehepaar
Lafontaine Wagenknecht eine wichtige
Rolle dabei bei dieser Zerlegung und sie
kommt deswegen glaube ich im Moment
nicht in Frage für die Leute die das
umtreibt worüber wir jetzt ausreichend
gesprochen haben und die AFD schöpft das
schöpft das offensichtlich erfolgreich
aber obwohl ja
die Linke genauso versucht bei den
Veranstaltungen sind ja
querveranstaltungen oder da schließt
sich dann ja auch wieder der politische
Kreis und
sie hat aber keinen Erfolg damit weil
sie glaube ich im Moment nicht als stark
und einheitlich wahrgenommen wird und
das hat sie sich selber
zuzuschreiben und diesem Bild dieser
dieser ganz offenen
Zerrüttung die die dazu für alle zu
erkennen ist und wer sich schwach
präsentiert wird von Wählerinnen und
Wählern dann nicht als Teil einer Lösung
und sei es in einer starken
Oppositionsrolle angesehen ist doch klar
vor allem wer sich so uneinig
präsentiert Sahra Wagenknecht hat eine
russische Rede im Bundestag gehalten und
da fragt man sich erklären warum das
doch irgendwie in Ordnung geht aber auch
wieder nicht ja genau und
linken Wählerinnen und Wählern können
die Linke dann nicht wählen so lange
Sarah Wagenknecht ein solchen
Stellenwert da noch hat und so eine Rede
halten kann ohne dass das Konsequenzen
für sie hat aber sie hat ja auch ein
große Fan-Gemeinde sind ja genau und das
ist genau der das ist genau
sie hat zumindest wo auch sie auf wo
immer sie auftaucht bei öffentlichen
Veranstaltungen hat sie in der Regel ein
paar tausend Zuschauern und Zuschauer
das ist kann kann man von anderen
Politiker nicht sagen okay welche wenn
man jetzt morgen am Montag wird
natürlich in allen parteigremen
analysiert wird geguckt wie reagieren
wir darauf welche Schlüsse ziehen wir
wenn die FDP jetzt wirklich nicht in
diesen Landtag kommt also diese 4,9% hat
die AFD ist so stark die SPD kann sagen
okay es ist der Amtsbonus von von Stefan
weil Frau renne Franz was würden Sie
sagen was wäre das wäre wichtigste
Schluss für die Ampelkoalition jetzt vor
auch für die SPD und die Grünen um jetzt
in diesen Herbst zu gehen in diesen
Winter wo viele sagen das wird alles
ganz furchtbar ich glaube da muss es
erstmal ein Gespräch mit Christian
Lindner geben und vor allen Dingen
müssten die da also für für Scholz ist
das ja jetzt ein großes Geschenk diese
Wahl also er kann da kriegt jetzt
wirklich so Rückenwind aus Niedersachsen
und ich glaube die müssen jetzt vor
allen Dingen erst mal überlegen wie Sie
mit dieser großen Frage wir hatten schon
angesprochen die da jetzt die ganze Zeit
im Raum stand Schuldenbremse wie sie
damit umgehen und wie sie quasi dem
Christian Lindner im gesichtswahnsinn
Ausweg zeigen weil die Schuldenbremse
also das wird nicht einzuhalten sein
nicht mit diesen Summen die da die da
ausstehen und wir reden ja nicht wir
haben jetzt immer überfrierende Menschen
geredet es geht ja auch wirklich um noch
um die Wirtschaft also ich war in
Thüringen letzte Woche carlappe großer
Porzellanhersteller macht jetzt zu wegen
der
Preise erstmal bis zum bis zum Winter
und das ist ja kein Einzelfall also die
die Ampel muss ich irgendwie
zusammenraufen also das sagt sich
natürlich hier am grünen Tisch immer
leichter ja als als dann in der in der
Realität aber man hat ja das Gefühl das
ist eher so ein Krampf und das so kann
es eigentlich nicht weitergehen und man
müsste dem dem Christian Lindner wie
gesagt dann eine Möglichkeit geben sich
von der Schuldenbremse zu distanzieren
ohne sich zu distanzieren
[Gelächter]
mai in der Sache ist es tatsächlich so
dass das ein bisschen
wie zu einer Art Fetisch geworden ist
wobei ich sagen würde im Prinzip das
sind wir wahrscheinlich einiges die
Schuldenbremse eine gute Sache aber es
ist eine Ausnahmesituation in Folge
einer vorigen Ausnahme Situation also
muss man eben noch mal eine Ausnahme
machen und sollte das vielleicht nicht
zu so einer Monstranz oder oder was auch
immer man wobei ich auch sage weil Frau
Dunst vorhin gesagt hat die eigene
Klientel wünscht sich schon Subvention
ich würde mich freuen wenn die
Wirtschaft auch in anderen
Zusammenhängen dann
mehr Etatismus fordern würde bei
Mindestlohn und solche Gedanken da war
immer zu viel Start und jetzt kann es
gar nicht genug Start und Subvention
sein lange Rede kurzer Sinn die
Koalition Frau rennefans hat vorhin
schon angedeutet kommt im Moment den der
Dringlichkeit der Entscheidung nicht
hinterher sie ist in den Entscheidungen
zu langsam das ist eindeutig der Zufall
hat es gefügt dass ich die letzten
Wochen in Frankreich zugebracht habe
frankreich hat längst diese da kann man
dann verstehen wie man will hat diese
energiepreisdeckel längst und
hämmerchron regiert jetzt auch nicht
kann auch nicht durchregieren wer ist
denn zu langsamer die Koalition
insgesamt also dieser dieser
letzte Runde auch mit den
Ministerpräsidenten das spielt der
Föderalismus durchaus auch eine hemmende
Rolle ja aber auch innerhalb ja auch
gesagt wir wollen erstmal nicht der Ware
sicher einig mit den anderen da war
eigentlich ein Scholz Seite an dass das
alles nicht so super ausgeht und das
sollte er vor der Wahl natürlich nicht
sagen er wollte sich nicht hinstellen um
Gottes Willen wir haben ja gar nicht
zustande gebracht das wäre jetzt auch
nicht so schön so in den Wahlsonntag zu
gehen fakt ist aber es geht zu langsam
und es hat auch mit diesen inneren
Fliehkräften dieser Koalition leider zu
schnell auch mit dem Föderalismus der
SPD langsam dann könnte man aber sagen
dann ist es Sache des Kanzlers Tempo zu
machen
und dieser Kanzler hat jahrelang erlebt
wie seine Vorgängerin das gemacht hat
Angela Merkel hat Debatten so lange
laufen lassen bis dann
finden selber zu einer klärenden
Richtung in eine klären Richtung
aufbrachen das wird er wahrscheinlich
das ist aber das ist jetzt sein Stil
aber das wird er nicht lange laufen
lassen können wenn er ja wenn ihn sonst
der Laden um die Ohren fliegt und eine
Sache zur Schulden wenn sie nachher
Lindner hatte im Wahlkampf ja einmal
davon gesprochen als ultima ratio könne
er sich auch vorstellen dass man davon
mal abweicht und das könnte er unter
Umständen auch wieder aufgreifen wollen
und sagen ich war eben nie der Betonkopf
sondern jetzt ist eine andere Situation
und jetzt ist es wirklich schlimm und
jetzt müssen wir es machen ich sehe es
auch als
Führungsschwäche von von Scholz was er
aber selber sich als Stärke
ausrechnet oder das selber von sich
findet dass das richtig ist wie er das
macht aber er wird da auf die Tube
drücken müssen und müsste dann habe ich
auch sagen ich bin jetzt kein Betonkopf
und muss mich von ein paar ideologischen
getrennt ich meine man muss sich mal die
das Anwerfen der Kohlekraftwerke
überlegen was das für eine Partei
bedeutet wie die Grünen das das ist ja
schon eine Menge dann die bei also jetzt
kann man sagen sind nur zwei AKWs die
erstmal weiter das ist ja das was immer
gefordert wird jetzt und was ihr
anscheinend in Niedersachsen auch
positiv bewertet wird dass man gesagt
hat also ich würde sagen die Grünen sind
schon ganz schön in Vorleistung getreten
ich sehe das jetzt bei der FDP noch
nicht so wahnsinnig wo die
Kernelemente aufgegeben haben vor allem
wenn man sie sehen Sie es bei den bei
den Grünen das Denken sie wie gestärkt
ist ist Haarwerk jetzt noch diese
Wahlergebnis die Grünen haben gut
zugelegt die haben gut zugelegt
allerdings nicht so wie es in den
Umfragen ja teilweise aussah und am
Sommer hatten die glaube ich so 22%,
also da sah es fast wie so ein
dreier-rennen aus wobei das ja bei den
Grünen auch so ein bisschen fast typisch
ist die Leute sagen in Umfragen immer
sehr gerne dass sie die Grünen wählen
und machen es dann vielleicht doch nicht
aber das ist natürlich eine Stärkung für
den Kurs
und ähm ja ich meine mehr ist
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht drin als
diese zwei
Atomkraftwerke und die Kohlekraftwerke
richtig finde ich es ehrlich gesagt
nicht ich finde in diesen Zeiten sollten
wir echt ähm ideologische Scheuklappen
ablegen und ich kann es halt echt nicht
verstehen wie man irgendwie wenn man
gasmangel hat und Strommangel vom
Blackouts redet und und so und dann sagt
nee aber wir halten jetzt fest an den an
den Abschaltzeiten dass das habe ich
nicht verstanden ich habe das ich habe
auch Merkel zur Reaktionen damals nicht
verstanden als sie nach Fukuyama den
Fukushima das war das war das Ende der
Geschichte
danke schön gesehen haben nicht so so
milde diese diese Frage der
Atomkraftwerke ja Habeck hat sich bewegt
aber a das hat ganz schön lange gedauert
und dann war die Bewegung erstmal nur so
ein kleines Schrittchen und dann
vielleicht noch ein Schrittchen und
vielleicht noch ein Schrittchen
eigentlich total gut verstehen wenn man
sich das Risiko bei dieser Technologie
das Risiko überlegt vor allem in dem
Zustand in dem diese AKWs jetzt sind
muss man doch auf jeden Fall dagegen
halten wenn diese drei Atomunfall wäre
mir ehrlich gesagt ist mir ein bisschen
höher und dann dann würde man im
Rückblick wieder sagen mann ihr wusstet
doch die sind 10 Jahre nicht gewartet
worden auf jeden Fall in Deutschland bei
den AKWs die wir haben halten sie
wirklich für so hoch dass wir erstmal
über Monate reden muss die man es
vielleicht nur länger laufen lassen
Sabotage Sabotage Attacke auf auf die
Deutsche Bahn erlebt ich glaube dass wir
sind da sehr empfindlich auch mit diesen
AKWs und sechs Prozent machen sie der
Stromerzeugung aus also ich meine das
könnte man und zwar alle drei und wenn
man jetzt eins abschaltet Russland weiß
ich nicht ob das jetzt zwei Prozent sind
oder oder etwas mehr aber da würde ich
sagen dann ist das schafft die
Bevölkerung in Frage stellen ob er habe
wirklich so konsequent und klar da
entschieden hat das hat er in meinen
Augen nicht sondern hat sich mit kleinen
Schrittchen da zu einer kleinen
Konzession hingelegt weil er die
Verunsicherung ist groß das haben auch
alle heute ja auch noch mal gesagt weil
alle die berichtet haben von den
Wahlkämpfen die verunsichert die
Menschen sind gibt es einen Punkt und
dann sie haben den sabotageaktt
angesprochen gibt es einen Punkt wo man
sagt das wäre jetzt eine richtige ein
richtiger tone richtige Ansprache in die
Gesellschaft die jetzt die man jetzt
braucht jetzt ganz wichtig wäre
naja ich finde zum Beispiel wirklich gut
wenn wir wenn erstmal irgendwie klar
gemacht würde noch viel stärker als
bisher dass das eine also warum wir das
machen und das ist eine temporäre Sache
ist und dass man alles tut um halt durch
den durch den Winter zu kommen und
dieses Gefühl dieses alles tun das
stellt sich bei mir auch noch nicht
richtig ein also das hat was mit den mit
den mit den Kraftwerken zu tun wie man
da mit umgeht das hat aber auch was mit
der gasumlage zu tun also ein paar
Fehler die da gemacht worden sind und
die Fehler gemacht okay gut wir reden
bald wieder in der Phönix Runde
natürlich über diverse Fehler und auch
Dinge die vielleicht gut laufen vielen
Dank erstmal heute abend Frau rennefans
verschwendicke Frau Dunz für die
Diskussion sie kennen das am Montag nach
Landtagswahlen werden Sie umfassende
informiert bei Phoenix den ganzen Tag
übernatürlich weil es viele
Pressekonferenzen gibt und da sind die
Kollegen die darüber berichten ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen für diesen Abend
bis dann tschüss
[Musik]
ein Landstrich mitten in Norddeutschland
überrascht mit seiner wilden Seite
[Musik]
Urwälder mit über 1000 Jahre alten
Bäumen
und Deutschlands größte Moore sind für
den Fotografen Willi